yeah robbie gets ready for his 15th
start of the season he's coming off his
fifth win of the year well first two
aboard against ray for kyle seeger
3-2 pitch
swung around and missed he struck him
out sager goes down swinging is where he
gets the first out of the inning
there's a slider he lays off oh compass
that he went around
no appeal at all the home plate umpire
damn belittle called it himself called
him for the swing
[Applause]
there's a line drive to right field but
they asked hernandez is there to make
the grab it was a long inning 30 pitches
for robbie ray but he strands a pair of
base runners
chris flexon making his 14th start of
the year mike and he is pitching some of
his best baseball of the year recently
right back to flexon
yeah sensing an early theme here
so guriel batting with grizzchick at
first in one out
squashed into right here that's a fair
ball it's gonna get all the way to the
wall richik is around second he's headed
for third and he'll pull up there as
they get the ball back in and guriel
picks up his 15th double of the season
and this is the depth of that blue jays
lineup there are hitters up and down the
order so marcus simeon will step in and
face flexing for a second time
fair ball down the third base line
that's going to score two grishik is in
the score and right behind him is hurtis
curiel jr and marcus simeon comes
through once again
a 3-2
two-run double for marcus simmon his
19th double of the season and that'll
give him 47 rbi eyes on the blue jays
the lead
ray's been been fantastic
raise ahead of you kyle seeger swings
and misses another good slider and a
strikeout for ray that's four strikeouts
so far
ty france strikes out for a second time
the high fastball gets him
there's a one hopper to marcus and it
was positioned perfectly
so robby ray now has found his groove
three up three down with a couple of
strikeouts in the fourth
left fielder lourdes goriel jr will lead
things off here in the bottom of the
fourth inning
jammed him and a soft fly ball out
towards right center fraley's been
fairly busy tonight
out towards right center fraley is
there
for round number two
secret drift team looking for the rolled
up tarp and he's got the room to make
the catch flexon retiring the side in
order for the first time tonight blue
chase have done a lot of damage
in innings one through five in the month
of june
laddie guerrero rips one fear down
line the first pitch base hits going to
be extra bases as he's digging for
second
he jumped on that first pitch and gets
himself a double
robotic guerrero
he's been on base all three times he's
come to the plate back-to-back walks
here in the fifth inning
high fly ball to left field not that
deep shed long into foul territory
tagging it there guerrero's
[Music]
[Applause]
continues to run the bases very well
cabin vizio will be rewarded with the
rbi his 18th of the season
here we go top of the six
lined into center field for a base hit
crawford aboard for the second time
anager lines this into left center field
crawford
has to hold at second took a bit of a
turn but retreats
one out two aboard for ty france ray to
the plate the first pitch fastball swung
on and driven deep to left
going back is the center fielder
springer on their track reaching up it's
down we get a tie ball game
time france delivers
home run number eight
oh right on time
just with the mariners needed crawford
scores energy scores france scores that
we got a new ball game here in the sixth
inning and to work the sixth it is
raphael montero here's beau bashette
well it's in high and deep into left
center this one's gonna go get out of
here
for that three-run home run
he breaks the tie immediately that ball
was smoked to the hanging breaking ball
from the reliever montero
now in baseball there's only three
players
in baseball who have had 50 rbis and 10
stolen bases in their first 75 team game
we were just talking about shohei ohtani
and then fernando tatis you know who the
third one is
beau buchet so now crawford bats with
long at first and fraley at third
semi into second for one back to first
double play what a play by guerrero
hey maintains contact with the back
taking the wide throw and the blue jays
turn a tough double play
the mariners
looks like they're going to have a look
at it
blue jays have been good at turning
double plays
i don't know if if it's first base
or if it's at second base we're not
there but if you look at that play right
there vladdy's foot was on the bag when
that ball hit his glove the umpire was
on it
he stretches
the foot stays on the bag the spike is
on it and if that's what they're going
to look at that should be an ounce
it is indeed an out
here's marcus simeon two more hits
tonight he drove into first two blue jay
runs with a double in the second
[Applause]
another two-strike home run for simeon
that's his seventh two strike home run
this season that leads the blue jays in
that category that's his 19th long ball
of the year
barnes making his 20-second appearance
overall he's actually pitched well since
he's come to the blue jays
and there's strike three call good
fastball from barnes
and there's a split change for the
strikeout
the golden sombrero for kyle seeger four
strikeouts tonight
called strike three breaking ball
catches the outside quarter and barnes
actually strikes out three in the inning
here's taylor saucedo making his fourth
appearance pitching into ninth
this should do it fly ball backing up
popped up to beau buchet and that's the
ball game saucedo gets j.p crawford the
bullpen pretty effective night of work
to back up robbie ray who strikes out 10
more and picks up the win as the blue
jays win the opener 9-3 over seattle